well coveted vaccines have arrived for
southern nevada's youngest children both
moderna and pfizer's versions have been
approved by the cdc for kids as young as
six months jeremy j ford spoke to
parents at a pediatrician's office today
considering the shot for their little
ones here at centennial pediatrics some
parents are getting their child a basic
checkup and inquiring about covet
vaccinations i've been waiting for this
moment just because i feel i'll feel a
lot safer taking my daughter out places
marissa ragsdale is ready to get her
little one vaccinated the earliest
appointment i can book i'm booking it
she's been waiting for the go ahead for
vaccines to be open for small children
this is just one way that parents can
make sure that their kids are
fully protected and
safe and healthy pediatrician dr michael
timby encourages parents to consider
these shots and we can get those
protection get the protection down for
those youngest children all the way down
to six months three shots are needed for
pfizer and two shots for moderna the
pfizer vaccine is actually a
one-tenth of the adult dose the modern
vaccine is one quarter of the adult dose
dr tinbee says you don't necessarily
need to have your pediatrician
administer it you can also get it at the
pharmacy if it's right for you go ahead
and do it if it's not right for your
family then you gotta respect it
everyone has to respect each other's
choices jeremy j ford live local now
all right jeremy thank you for that well
the southern nevada health district has
also started administering covet
vaccines to kids under the age of five
at its facilities now you can find
clinic locations on our website
eightnewsnow.com